hello my name is jose martin garcia and
i will be talking about geo computation
we will be talking about new additions
and the functionality to support all the
geo computations in the bottom language
i'm going to talk about another of the
main part of the geo project this geo
computation so the competition is a very
general term and we could include
virtually everything here but for us in
the award from language because we have
so many other functions outside the geo
of functionality itself that do many
things we can concentrate on on a
smaller set of things so the fundamental
expects of computation in the geo
project are first everything that
relates to measuring and computing
distances arias and goals things like
own checking membership or something
inside something how this sort of thing
then we have another aspect which is
cartographic geo projections this is a
very important part of the system
because it's going to determine very
much the actual shape of the final map
then we have Geographics itself
Geographics is the basis of virtually
everything in the in visualizing geo
data and it has a lot of computation
inside in estimations of things in
deciding resolutions how many points do
we need to convert geo circle into
standard graphics primitive this sort of
thing and then there is the geophysical
modelling in the sense of having data
and computation about the gravitational
field we have now tides information
recently got magnetic fields etc but I'm
not going to go into that the
functionality has been improving
steadily inversions 10 both in coverage
and speed and in their recent versions
we have focused a lot in making
Geographics more robust and fast and
main
recent driver for this effort has been
the new function G of image because
Geographics was very much based on on
texture and we cannot use that in in
your image so we had to change a number
of things in order to support your image
with the same basically the same
functionality that is behind your
graphics so my plan for this talk is
first to summarize the existing
functionality like like Francisco did
for geo data it will just be an slide
slide then I will present a couple of
functions which are recent well actually
why we we just add it and the other one
we will be just adding and then I
thought that in this talk I would
address a number of frequent questions
that come to us things that have been
asked frequently recently okay so the
with respect to measuring we have our
main player here is your position I
wanted to express how flexible is your
position is it can be added or can be
used basically some sort of
pre-processing function because you can
pass that along to the opposition but
also a lot along height you can add
dates here as absolute times in GMT time
zone so that the position doesn't have
to worry about time zones you can add
lists of those positions this is very
flexible because you can have all data
here medically packed so it's very fast
for computation and then of course we
have the datum argument which is very
flexible and it allows a number of
models of the earth and also using other
celestial bodies but I talked a lot
about datums last year so I'm not going
to go into that this year just as an
example you can see here how the
opposition is able to take
simultaneously numeric data parsing
various forms of string input in various
forms quantities as well various units
it will fetch data for entities etc it
will be all translated into a single
form you can extract data for from
images it can access
real-time data like the current position
of International Space Station or as I
said data in other planets and moons the
only restriction is that the dimension
has to be constant consistent so for
example here all points have to lat/long
here we have three here we have four so
we can mix this this dimensionally
different data other than that if they
are in the same body you can mix them in
an array and it's recommended there are
other specification for locations but
I'm not going to go into that today then
with respect to G or computation itself
we have different types we have the
fundamental geodetic computation based
on geodesics and have these functions to
compute distances directions to start
from our place and go to another one so
for example if we are here in Champaign
and we want to go to the 0 0 of lateral
coordinates we have to move sixth modern
fixtures of 6000 miles along a geodesic
and interestingly we have to start
nearly East only less than a degree from
East but that's the direction we have to
start in order to arrive geologically
add the zero zero we have other types of
measures for length areas lateral bounds
etcetera yes and another thing I wanted
to stress here is that some of these
computations are local they are
performed in Jurong machine so that's
quite fast other computations like what
Francisco's presenting before travel
directions and Joe entities related
stuff which is very entity based we do
these in the Geo server itself so we
transfer our information to the server
so that all the entities are processed
there and we perform the computation
there and bring it back so this has
advantages sometimes when you are
handling lots and lots of entities but
when it there are a few the overhead of
the transmission may be larger than the
actual computation so for example to
avoid that we have added support for the
Opposition in recent versions since 11
in
in Fournier lists so nearest now can do
part of this and the computation will be
local so it's a lot faster so for
example here the opposition we extract
all the opposition's for the capitals of
the states of the United States
and nearest can say what's the closest
capital to here right and you see these
computations are all performed already
with the geo position data so we don't
need the entity data has been processed
that's why nearest can do it and just to
show you a difference here in timing so
we start with say a thousand random
points here nearest we'll find which one
is the closest to us in milliseconds
while sending all these thousand points
to the geoserver do a computation and
bringing it back will take like three
seconds okay well so that was my my very
quick summary of what we have so as
Francisco's in relation to two
fundamental to your computation as
Francisco mentioned the images is
probably the main new thing we have
recently and it works very much like
Geographics except for five important
differences first of all that output is
an image not a Geographics object
Geographic is basically a graphics
itself and so yes because image doesn't
have a notion of meters or any other
units other than that than ten pixels so
now it will decide itself which the size
of the result rather than we can turn it
from Geographics another important
difference is that Steven wanted your
image to be always satellite by default
rather than street map as Geographics
does the default just sorry this is not
your style this is your projection the
different geo projection for your image
is Mercator rather than this automatic
choice that Geographics does right so
this is because nearly all other
systems use the Mercator so we wanted to
align our limiters with what the actual
provider sent us yes so your image
allows itself to automatically switch to
the digital globe provider when you ask
for a deeper soon
so in Geographics if you want something
very deep something a very low scale
like kilometers it will complain it
doesn't happen you have to manually say
I want to use your server goes to
digital globe here but in the image by
default it will use the Oh graph sorry
digital off for very low scales and for
larger scales like like this one it will
reduce be using our own tiles so there
is a transition there and that's why for
the whole wall I have to use this it's
also because I wanted to use satellite
with the labels so I I don't know
whether you see them but these this has
labels here for the countries okay so
that's an image and as I was saying
before the image has motivated a
restructuring of much of Geographics to
do to process they're all the giants and
image internal in a different way so the
result can be shared with with gel image
okay
a recent function we have added which is
a simple but quite useful is geo
antipode so do Antep on let's see if the
connection the connection yeah it's
working here so do do antipode is just
going to compute the antipode to a given
location if you give a location which is
just flipping the sign of latitude and
then log it it it will either add 90 or
so stagnating depending on the sign of
the original thing like geo position
thus it will collapse entities into a
position first and then return the
antipode for that then in spain we all
know that madrid has its antipode in new
zealand so very famous fact there on
your primitives it will try to get to
return another primitive if it can if
not for example with a polygon it will
just flip all the coordinates in the
polygon for the night for the day
hemisphere for example by definition
it's the night hemisphere is the
antipode of that now we can flip that
and for example again here we see how
New Zealand when when computed the
antipode Falls very much on Spain we can
do that for example for Antarctica right
so we are now computed the antipode of
the polygon of Antarctica so now we see
how an Antarctica would look on the
North Pole we can do that even for the
for whole world so we can compare where
were I know the United States would fall
there ocean and for example Francisco's
mentioning there before North Korea so
if you wanted to be very very far from
North Korea should go South America okay
the new function I'm we're going to have
very soon it's called do rotate and what
generative does is basically taking any
position or polygon the earth and move
it somewhere else based on a three
dimensional rotation so remember we have
three parameters there so for example if
we take the polygon of the US and we
rotate it this is the language is
basically saying well take the geodesics
that your district that goes from here
to Paris which is that one so then you
will just move the basically parallel
transport the polygon of the US until
there and in the process it will get
rotated that's because we are only
controlling two of the parameters of the
of the rotation we can add the third
parameter that would rotate it back to
the orientation you want so these can be
always tough for any projection so I
don't know it's it's very typical to
talk about for example negative let's
see if this works
yes so so how different projections
affect the shape of off of a given
polygon so we go we can play and see how
the United States you see it will be
able to cover Greenland for example
right what if you move it closer to the
equator it will look much smaller than
it typically looks comparison with
Australia for example
as I go saying a rotation through every
3d rotation has three degrees of freedom
and the general language to control that
is to specify the point which is kind of
the axis of rotation plus the rotation
you want to rotate around that axis so
we can do that and what we end up with
is is this sort of thing so if I start
no I'm going the other direction so if I
start with the polygon of the US here
right and I rotate around the North Pole
well it's going to rotate horizontally
right that's fine but now if I change
the axis of rotation so I bring it down
like like I don't know like there then I
I can start again from the original
polygon which is there but now when I
move it to see it will be following this
path between two new parallels right and
not how this North East part of the US
is always perpendicular to the parallel
right so the rotation is happening just
to keep that to keep the orientation so
the northeast part keeps being
perpendicular that's the origin of the
rotation we were seen before and you can
yeah this allows you these three
parameters allows you are fully general
3d rotation on the earth
so that's your rotate and it will be
coming soon
my plan for the rest of the talk is to
address one of these questions that have
been asked a number of times which for
example one is well what what is the
meaning of the coordinates that you plot
in the final map and how can I make that
to be miles for example right so the
that's controlled with this option of
the projection which is called reference
model and by default we have there one
which means that when you plot a map
typically when you activate the tick's
with frame true you see the ticks here
it will say one two this would be of
order one this is pretty much random
choice just for for homogeneity but if
you want to to use miles what you have
to do is to put there the number of
miles corresponding to the radius of the
of the earth and then once you do that
so so compute the radius of the earth in
miles which is that number we put it
there reference to that now this map
will report miles here now it most maps
distort distances so you cannot trust
these distances everywhere so typically
there is a region of the map for the
orthographic projection is the center to
see Reno here in which in which
distances are correct but if you go
further from the region the distances
will not be correctly reported so for
example some for some projections there
is something called the standard
parallels which allows you to specify
where those lines of proper measuring
are in the circle those are called
external powers so for example for the
for the for the for the Alvarez
projection there are these two lines so
we have again the the ticks being miles
and so these are miles are correct but
are correct only along those lines and I
can choose which to line so you see that
the the map will change shape and depend
so that those two lines are correct so
if if they are equal
the map will look kind of nice in Moodle
except so depending but you always have
one line which is correct or two and by
the way you see how when I move in this
the full map is being represented there
is an image transformation of the whole
map etc and that's one of the things
which have which we have made recently
so so this is now smoother experience
when we use manipulate with with
Geographics second question which I get
very frequently is how do I get a square
map because the maps in Geographics are
very much controlled by the Geo range
and of course when you specify say six
degrees of geo range in Italy fine
in the equirectangular projection that
which is faithful to last long that's a
square map but that's not the proper
shape of Italy
that's very compressed vertically so the
proper shape is this one but now this is
much longer than this one even though
it's still representing six degrees this
is six degrees of flat line just that
these coordinates are now different
coordinates so how do you do that how
did you get a square map of this region
well the way to do this is to control
the map via the plot range which is the
range of the projected map and so you do
that by extracting the projection
corresponding to that region which was
decided by Geographics and now you say
Geographics of those projected
coordinates and as you yes you have full
control on the size now you see now have
six with this option and now this map is
fully square of course it's going to be
a smaller region but it's fully square
right so that's how do you control the
the aspect ratio of the final maps you
can do this for example for any other
aspect ratio so now if we want to aspect
ratio to so this is double distance and
this then we just have to say well 4
isn't aliy I want 12 units here and
vertically I want six so that now if
respect is respected because this is the
plot range not the zero range and this
trick works in
absolutely any projection so for example
this is the winkel Tripel projection now
with we are coordinates here because I'm
still keeping the the reference model
goes to one I extract the projection
from the map because your graphics
chooses automatically some parameters
like this one and I put it back but now
I control the shape of the final map
with the plot wrench and now this map
again is fully squared so four four four
presentations and always for our
marketing pitches etc we want order for
be in square etc this is a very frequent
question another frequent question is
what's the difference between line and
geo path yes this also appears very
frequently so here I'm going to take the
same two cities Oslo and Chicago and I'm
going to draw three lines one is a
geodesic another one is a number line a
loxodrome another one is a pure line
what we call line in graphics if I put
them in the map we see red is the
geodesic blue is the straight line line
is always a straight your paths will be
genetically be curved and now this is
the block Salaam I can put them in other
projection and you see even the
positions change so here the blue line
is in between the other two here the
blue line is over the green line yes
under the green line here is over the
other two it changes a lot but the
important thing is that for example
notice how the geodesic always goes
through Iceland and Greenland ice line
and this line Iceland and Greenland
Iceland so these are really physically
defined the the line is just a straight
line and this problem is even worse for
polygons if you give three points and
you ask for the triangle to get that one
but the geodesic triangle is that other
one the red one they don't even touch it
they don't even overlap at any point
right so there is a big difference
between geodesic triangles and triangles
and we control that always using the
difference between
line and geo path and again I can change
the projection and now they fully
overlap so this depends a lot on the
projections you always have to think
what you are what you want to do whether
you want something on the earth or
something on the map so you have the
data there and then the final question I
have here is again the difference
between geo centers centering and grid
origin so we have these three parameters
that control very related things but
they are different actually so for
example the I'm only looking here at the
at the longitude this is GC lon
is the we have it it's here the Geo
Center so the Geo Center defines the
center of the region I want to see so
you see that's always kind of in the
middle of the region of the earth I'm
looking at then we have long zero which
is what is at the center of the
coordinates so you see how this blue
point stays the same that's the lone
zero and is what is here at zero zero
the point of the earth that will fall at
zero zero and then the the other one the
grid origin is just a shift of the whole
thing so in a sense then the the
centering is always mapped to the grid
origin so controlling these things
allowed me to for example again let's go
back to Korea and draw North Korea let
let's draw like like a number of geo
circles of different distances around
North Korea which start there and then
this is 2000 kilometers 4000 kilometers
6000 kilometers etc for example if we
change to another projection this is
going to be a nicer well to understand
what's going on and good are equivalent
distances but still because your lumber
assimil makes an effort to preserve
areas
we don't get a proper representation of
distances well now with another
projection which is a see Metallica
distance these circles are all of
corresponding like radiuses and is
easier to understand we see how it's
South America which is being stretched
here as the farthest thing from from
this central point so again you see how
different projections allow you to
visualize things in in different ways
and yeah that's it that's exactly 525
minutes thank you
[Applause]